my name is Elizabeth Furyk I'm the
executive director of the Anne Frank
Center USA it gives me great pleasure to
welcome you here and to extend the warm
welcome to the author we have all come
to be introduced to tonight miss Carol
Ann Lee and to welcome Harper Collins
this book we are learning more about
this evening is entitled the hidden life
of otto Frank and it's just published
and out in the bookstores here in the US
on February 4th I believe that happened
when we consider the subject of the book
otto frank our organization is the place
to host this book discussion and the
book signing afterwards the history of
the Frank family is painful and complex
material made even more complicated by
the fact that the majority of people who
are part of their history are no longer
alive yet our curiosity leaves many
questions any project that involves
retracing and analyzing exactly what
happened and through whom and why isn't
impressive undertaking that said however
given the controversy in the Netherlands
that the theory presented here in this
book on Otto gave rise to when the Dutch
version came out late last spring and
the resulting statement from the
Netherlands Institute for war
documentation who reopened an
investigation we have to join those that
cannot endorse the presented thesis as
very viable fact until this independent
study confirms it as that simultaneously
facts connected to the life and history
of the Frank family and in Otto being
the most famous among them are of course
always of interest to us and we welcome
the introduction and exploration of
Caroline Lee's theories here tonight
freedom of speech is a precious right
and is essential in the research of any
theory and in the exploration of the
conclusions an author draws
now without further talk for me because
it isn't me you came here to here I
would like to introduce to you miss
Carol Ann Lee well first of all I would
like to say thank you very much to
everybody for coming and also of course
to everybody at the Anne Frank Center
here for inviting me I consider it a
really great honor to be at the end
Frank center first of all but also to be
in America and especially New York which
I've really fallen in love with in just
the two days that I've been here what
I'm going to do is I'm going to read a
few pages from the book and then I'll
tell you a little bit about how I came
to write the book and why I wrote the
book and then afterwards of course
anybody who wants to ask questions I'll
be happy to answer anything okay the
chapter I'm going to read from deals
with autos last days in Auschwitz autumn
brought mist and rains to the vast open
expanse of Auschwitz as the Allies
progressed throughout Europe Himmler
ordered an end to the gassings at
Auschwitz the Nazis gradually began to
destroy all evidence of the final
solution a group of 1700 Jews from
teresa's that were the last to enter the
gas chambers on October the 28th 1944
the following day there was announcement
there was an announcement in the men's
barracks that qualified physicians were
allowed to transfer to another camp in
Germany Fritz Pfeffer who was one of the
people who was in hiding with the Franks
applied to leave feeling that his
chances of survival were better there
Ottawa recalled that he and Pfeffer had
grown closer during their time in
Auschwitz as long as we were together he
discussed more frankly personal matters
with me than he had done during the time
of our hiding Pfeffer was one of 60
doctors who boarded the train that day
and disappeared into the unknown again
in november otto was sent to work
indoors given the task of peeling
potatoes
Joseph's prawns whom Otto would later be
free
and had the same duty for a while and
outlines the work in his memoir we had
to carry up to 80 pounds of potatoes to
fill the kitchen basin the potatoes were
meant for animals only the biggest ones
were peeled and the rest were thrown
into the machine unpeeled it was very
tiring work but instead of becoming
weaker which we had expected
we grew stronger thanks to the turnips
and other vegetables which we were
eating from morning to evening together
with some leftover bread of course we
only did that when the SS weren't
looking we felt we were living like
princes the biggest drawbacks were the
heavy beatings dealt out and the
punishments for stealing those peeling
the potatoes were searched three times a
day and those caught stealing something
got a horrible beating and were put into
another commando where they had to work
with sewage all the same many of us took
the risk of smuggling food from the
kitchen the carp was very often forced
us to smuggle in food for them
we were not beaten up for that we also
bartered potatoes for bread one carpo
took a powerful dislike to otto and beat
him regularly Otto's health began to
fail slowing his work rate which
resulted in further attacks at one point
Otto had a fight with another inmate
during an interview conducted with
Otto's second wife in the 1980s it
emerged that when otto returned to
amsterdam after the war he asked me
please to go with him to visit the owner
of a shoe shop otto told me i want to
visit this man because i had a fight
with him in the camp i punched him in
the face
Miep was shocked by this revelation it
was not the sort of thing she imagined
otto doing
although worried about the visit she
accompanied otto to the shop the owner
recognized otto instantly and walked
towards him there was a brief moment of
hesitation and then he and Otto embraced
utter explained later in the camp's
tempers could run high at times because
of small unimportant things evidently
this man had done something Otto did not
like but after the war it was forgot
sometime in November 1944 Otto reached
the limits of his endurance severely
depressed starving and wracked with
diarrhea he was unable to lift himself
from his bunk
he remembered on a Sunday morning I
could not get up being exhausted from
hard work and little food and having
been beaten the day before by the carpo
that had really affected me also in
terms of my morale I said I can't get up
and then my comrades all Dutchman I was
the only German but they totally
accepted me said that's impossible you
must get up because otherwise you are
lost someone sent for the doctor who
happened to be a Jewish man from
Amsterdam Otto recalled this Dutch
doctor came to my barracks he said get
up and come to the sick barracks
tomorrow morning and I'll speak to the
German doctor and you will be saved and
this is what happened and through it I
was saved the doctor who had mitad Otto
to the hospital remembered visiting Otto
in the barracks after the war and
finding him incredibly filthy and
covered with lice this doctor said when
he was talking about that memory
Otto begged me doctor please help me and
I went to a Jewish Czech colleague
Fischer to ask him for advice Fisher was
neurologist an extraordinary man and he
was willing to admit otto frank for
psychological observation
thus otto front was hospitalized and
tucked away in a corner where he still
was when the Russians liberated him in
the hospital at Auschwitz
Otto met Joseph's Proms who became a
lifelong friend sprung survived in
Auschwitz in June 1944 from Budapest he
had been sent to the hospital when his
hands were badly burned during an
accident in the kitchens spons made
friends with a Hungarian doctor who
asked him to act as his assistant in the
hospital sponsors second wife Franzi
recalls how her husband and Otto met in
the hospital my husband formed a circle
of people who despite their illnesses
or whatever had brought them there were
interested in music literature and art
they each took turns to sing or recite
one evening my husband was whistling a
few batt bars of Beck's
st. Matthews passion and Otto appeared
walking slowly towards him also
whistling the tune when it was over Otto
said I know that you are a Hungarian and
I am NOT but please may I join you and
your friends they invited him to sing or
give a speech and he stood up and
recited hinds poem about losing his
religion in his memoir of Auschwitz
speranza explains that inmates of the
hospital had their Footwear and clothes
stolen in return they were given thin
night shirts if that the hospital was
designed much the same as the regular
barracks and the food was no better
ron's recalls in the hospital people got
less food than the men who worked
elsewhere this was meant to be a
deterrent otherwise to many people would
have schemed to get there we had more
time to realize how hungry we were and
to contemplate a low morale which was
greater in the hospital we also had more
time to become aware of how precarious
fate was for our loved ones and how
little hope our own present situation
held for us Otto's admission to the
hospital coincided with the end of the
gassings
and it was at least somewhat safer than
the rest of the camp the weather was
appalling and the hospital did did offer
slightly more protection from the
elements snow fell on Auschwitz that
December and thousands of inmates died
in a letter written a few months later
otto recounts a sorrowful memory of
Christmas in Auschwitz the last music I
heard was at Christmas in the camp when
two comrades played violin and cello
very nicely in the hospital he added I
know that they are dead now in the first
days of 1945 the boom of Russian
artillery and the crackling of automatic
rifles could be heard not far from
Auschwitz in mid-january these sounds
were joined by the rumble on the roads
of fleeing via macht via
calls knowing that the Red Army was
closing in the SS began to destroy
sections of its colossal death factory l
shrits gas chambers were brought blown
up crematoria were demolished and scores
of barracks electrified fences and the
guard tells at Birkenau were torn down
clothes spectacles suitcases jewelry and
other belongings from the dead were sent
to Berlin while in the camp itself
documents and registers were set on fire
corpses from mass graves were exhumed
and burned in open pits but the Germans
continued to torture and murder
prisoners On January the 12th the Red
Army Army penetrated the inadequate
German defenses the inmates in the
hospital heard the news as Franz
recalled when the German lines were
pierced we grasped at once that this
would mean the evacuation of the camp
excitement was enormous On January the
16th Russian planes attacked altruists
destroying the kitchen and food depot in
Birkenau On January the 17th units of
the Red Army approached outlying areas
of cracker from the north and northwest
surprising the German forces a decision
had already been reached about what to
do with the outreach prisoners those who
could walk would be evacuated on foot
and eventually put to work those in the
hospital like Otto would be abandoned as
fog obscured the roads around the camp
and snow continued to fall heavily ash
whit's itself lay silent finally exposed
to imminent assault the young man walked
quickly through the snow in Auschwitz
one main camp keeping his head down
Peter Pham Pels 19 years old had made
the journey from his own barracks in the
camp hospital almost every evening for
two months otto later recalled peter
acted like a son to help me every day he
brought me extra food he never could
stay long we never discuss serious
matters and he never spoke about Anne I
did not have the impression that he
matured much Peters visit to the
hospital on the night of January the
18th 1945 would be
lest he was leaving Auschwitz and he
helped to persuade Otto to do the same
Otto had heard at noon that day that the
camp was to be evacuated his friend
Josef Franz remembered at midnight the
SS roused physicians and nurses and me
as well we were deeply frightened by the
order to burn the sick cards of all
personnel and the patients then in the
hospital this might have meant the
extermination of all unable to walk it
was very painful for both physicians and
nurses to abandon the sick yet we had to
do it to prove our fitness sprung then
found Otto and told him to stay in the
hospital if he possibly could
Otto took his advice hiding in the
toilets when he felt the situation was
becoming dangerous he recalled of that
evening it was 20 below zero Peter came
to me and said we leave he was well fed
and had a good position he was young he
told me I'm working with them I'll make
it I said Peter hide yourself you can
hide yourself here in the hospital
upstairs or somewhere but Peter was too
afraid he would be discovered and shot
and felt that his best chance for
survival was the March he and Otto
argued about this and finally Peter left
the hospital alone Otto cried when he
had gone Peter was a very good boy
really a good-hearted boy he says he was
convinced that Peter would not survive
the March and knew that his hope of
helping the young man to develop his
potentialities in the future would now
never be realized outside the snow
continued to fall shortly after midnight
the first column of prisoners began
marching away from Auschwitz in Birkenau
the temperature dropped at mber degrees
below zero when the SS started pulling
the prisoners out of their barracks onto
the snow-covered fields and bullying
them into the customary ranks of five
even then there were long delays roll
calls shouts and confusion several
thousand prisoners in the camp Hospital
argued about whether to join the
evacuation and those who wanted to flee
fought over the few pairs of wooden
clogs that the guards
left them to use in going to the
latrines groups left at intervals
throughout the night in the following
day the women and children from Burke
now left first then the men from the
camp sometimes there would be only 100
prisoners in a column but there were
also groups of over two thousand people
who set off on foot westward towards the
cities of Silesia reaching the railway
stations prisoners were pushed into open
goods wagons and sent on journeys that
sometimes lasted more than a week
without food or water
the majority perished and those who
survived through the bodies of the
frozen dead onto the railway track and
licked snow off the ledges of the wagons
to ease their thirst and hunger
prisoners forced to march the entire way
into Germany were beaten shot starved
and offered little assistance from the
ordinary civilians they passed at 1:00
a.m. on January the 19th the last
transport of two thousand five hundred
prisoners waited by BER canals death
Gate documents and clothing still burned
inside the camp the lights on the main
switchboard close to the entrance gate
were flicked out and darkness descended
upon the camp the prisoners marched down
to Auschwitz one to await further orders
6,000 prisoners too sick to march among
them otto frank remained behind but the
camp was once more a silent paid plain
in the woods fields and villages of
Upper Silesia 58,000 former inmates
marched through appalling weather many
of them freezing to death while far
below the grim and partly gutted ruins
of Auschwitz lay abandoned in the snow a
few hours after the last prisoners who
could walk left the camp Allied aircraft
launched an attack on the IG Farben
factories very close to Auschwitz one
the heads of the factories set fire to
their archives for otto Frank and the
1,200 inmates of Auschwitz one the
Allied raid may have helped their morale
but was a disaster in immediate
practical terms it cut the water and
electricity supplies to the camp the
whole place was plunged into complete
darkness it was like being
apt in a sunken ship there was no light
food or drinking water just starvation
and thirst and outside a perpetual black
fog the prison compound was buffeted by
waves of rain and wind while the sky
above shook with bombs from the Red Army
forces Auto recalled what followed after
the Germans left we were alone people
from the hospital and quite a number we
found so much food sellers of food
belonging to the SS but there was no
water because everything was frozen and
broken there were lakes in the
neighborhood so we went to break the ice
and then we had water sponge remembered
every patient who was able to move was
busy carrying water to the kitchen only
boiled water was drunk and black coffee
was constantly available inmates from
Berk know where the SS had set fire to
the warehouses containing prisoners
clothing and belongings and shot 200
women at random also managed to salvage
food from the supplies in the main camp
aside from this the fog and rain
sustained their chilled is fondant grip
and the rumor spread that the Russians
were still only in the zakopane
Mountains far away from the haunted ramp
of Birkenau it began to sleet heavily on
January the 25th at 2 o'clock in the
afternoon a group of SD men strode into
a streets one five days earlier the head
of the Auschwitz liaison and transition
officers had received an order to
liquidate every last prisoner in the
camps of Birkenau and al shrits dozens
of armed SS entered the hospital
barracks screaming at the patients and
dragging them from their beds otto and
his comrades were forced to their feet
and marched down the camp street towards
the main gate prisoners emerged from the
decaying barracks spindling as the SS
punched and kicked them through a path
of frozen snow the SD yelled orders to
the SS who moved swiftly among the
prisoners pushing them into line German
Reich prisoners formed the first two
rows followed by Aryans than other Jews
and finally those inmates unable to
stand were dropped at the back on the
ground photo stood in the middle knowing
exactly
why we were there we knew we were
finished spawns was also among the
prisoners the SD began to consult one
another we realized that an execution
was to come for leaving the camp in an
organized way was out of the question
the Germans were displaying their hand
grenades and machine guns and we felt
the bullets penetrating into our bodies
already those were moments of mortal
anguish the SD lined up before the
prisoners in a single row under the
black iron gate bearing the maxim work
brings freedom the sleet turned to rain
as they raised their machine guns
an officer stepped forward to give the
order to fire suddenly three loud
snapping explosions echoed in the air
the prisoners in the front row looked at
one another in a daze no one had been
killed there were two further explosions
clearly from outside the camp and then
an armored car appeared from the main
road carrying several SS men one of them
jumped out and addressed the officer in
charge of the murder squad the exchange
was brief but plainly urgent as they
were talking a small convoy of cars
pulled up beside the main gate the
conversation between the two men ended
and the officer motion to the guards
they threw their guns over their
shoulders and ran toward the vehicles
return to barracks yelled the officer to
the bewildered prisoners before climbing
into the kairos nearest him the guards
no longer paid the inmates any attention
and within seconds every vehicle was
gone the stunned prisoners including
auto began to walk back to the barracks
helping each other along the windswept
camp Street they discussed what they
should do
Franzese prawns record recounts the
story told to her by her husband the
Germans have fled and were not coming
back there were cowards everyone
the prisoners wondered what to do next
during the confusion Otto found my
husband and said he was sure that the
end must be closed and he was determined
to survive until the Russians arrived so
that he could return home and be with
his children again my husband gave him
his address and then they parted
liberation came quietly
two days later on the morning of January
the 26th the SS returned to Berk now and
dynamited one of the crematoria before
leaving in armored cars in the early
hours of January the 27th via mock
troops blew up the railway bridge over
the Vistula and solar rivers and a
wooden bridge over the solar that had
been built by post prisoners from
Auschwitz at 3 o'clock in the afternoon
as snow was once more beginning to fall
recognizance Scouts from the 1st
Ukrainian front wearing white capes made
their way out of the woods near al ships
and saw the barbed wire of the camp as
they advanced upon the gate a group of
German soldiers appeared a fierce battle
ensued which ended with the Germans
running off and two Russian soldiers
being fatally injured elsewhere in the
area 231 Red Army soldiers died while
fighting to liberate al sure it's in its
sub camps after removing a number of
mines from the area the Red Army finally
entered the compound of Auschwitz 1 when
the soldiers entered the hospital otto
frank was too weak and overcome to stand
up to greet them he could only register
register his liberators snow white coats
they were good people we did not care if
they were communists or not we were not
concerned with politics we were
concerned about our liberation that's
the end of the section I wanted to read
and and I read that particular section
because so much of the press is focused
on the betrayal theory that Elizabeth
mentioned and I want to make it clear
tonight the one thing I do want to make
it clear is that although the betrayal
thing is an element of the book it is
not the most important part of the book
and not even for me the book is a
biography of Otto Frank and it's a very
dramatic story perhaps I should tell you
how I came to actually write the book
for me it goes back a long long way I
was 6 years old when I first read about
Anne Frank it was a children's retelling
of the
and I don't know why but it just really
gripped me and then when I was about
eight years old I read the diary for the
first time and I couldn't understand
everything that was in it at that age of
course but what did appeal to me very
much was Anne's character and I kept
reading the book as I was growing up
going through my teenage years I kept
reading it and I would always find some
new elements in it and I can still find
that today when I was about 18 I wanted
to find out more about the background to
am story more about why she was in that
situation and what had happened to her
afterwards too but there were no no real
biographies about her so I decided I
wanted to write one myself and I began
that when I was 18 years old and I've
been collecting material on Anne Frank
since I first read about her when I was
six and I had quite a collection um and
so I wrote two sample chapters and I
sent them off to the Valentine Mitchell
publishers in London and they were very
interested in publishing it but they
said well you know she's 18 she's not
Jewish she doesn't have the background
in this so perhaps it's not the right
time at least so I put it to one side
and then I went off to university and
after university I worked in a bookstore
and then while I was working there I
suddenly thought well there's still no
books available about Anne Frank as such
and so then I thought okay I'm going to
really really research this well now and
that's what I did and that about a month
later I had an agent and my contracts
with Penguin Books and I'd made good
contacts with them Budi Elias who's in
charge of the Anne Frank forms in
Switzerland and Anne's last surviving
very close relative and that book came
out and from that book this book emerged
I wrote the children's biography of Anne
Frank to my publisher in Britain wanted
a children's version and then I went
Switzerland to give a talk with buddy
and while I was talking I was talking at
quite at length about Otto Frank um
somebody in the audience stood up and
said you know you you rightly talk so
well about Otto why don't you consider
him as a subject for your next book and
I went away and I thought about it and I
thought well yes because he had such a
remarkable life he lived through two of
the greatest disasters of the the you
know the 20th century the song he
survived the battle of the somme he
survived Auschwitz he was the one who
had to deal with the diary being
published and what his daughter became
in the public public mind and you know I
was very interested too in the dichotomy
between his circumstances in the first
world war where he fought for his
country and the second where he was
persecuted by that same country and so I
thought yes I would like to write this
book and I spoke to Booty again and I
said you know would you mind me digging
into your family history yet again and
he said well I think it's a great idea
for a book but I don't think anybody
will be interested but that didn't put
me off because by then I already knew I
wanted to write it and so I started by
going over the notes I already had for
my and Frank book and and then I was
very fortunate that with the otto frank
book i was able to go into the archives
of the anne frank sting and I got
contact names I interviewed lots of
people and and so the book emerged and I
know like I said so much of the press
has focused on the betrayal in the book
but for me the most remarkable discovery
was this diary that otto Frank himself
kept from the moment of his liberation
until the time when he arrived back in
Amsterdam in the summer of 1945 and it's
a remarkable document because of course
there are many very moving Holocaust
memoirs but this is a book that he wrote
on the journey back and I personally
don't know of any other books that have
been published like that they may well
be some
but I found that very very moving
because you actually see the moment when
he discovers his wife is dead he writes
about that and you also see he writes
every now and then that you know he's so
sure his children will have survived and
you know that's why he's going back to
Amsterdam of course because he feels so
sure they will be there for him and the
diary ends his little notebook actually
ends when he arrives back in Amsterdam
and so for me that was the most moving
discovery and what I would like to say
too is that I hope that people who buy
the book will find it interesting and
one of the reasons I wrote it was
because I think a lot of people have a
very the image we have of otto frank or
had of Otto Frank myself included was
that he was this ideal father figure and
there wasn't much else to him apart from
that and he was he was a wonderful
father there's no doubt about that but
he was a human being and a man in his
own right and of course he had strengths
and weaknesses like the next person so
what I hope to have achieved with the
book is that he has seen very much as a
person in his own right at last and not
just as the father of Anne Frank
um I think that's the end of what I want
to say but if anybody would like to ask
questions at all I if you want to ask a
question
- the microphone comes to you so the
question can be heard my problem with
the whole book is hidden what is hidden
the blackmail
why was he blackmailed because of the
collaboration take the whole thing out
and there's nothing left there are very
moving and interesting stories about
other Frank in the book and for my point
of view it should be the life of Otto
Frank or whatever other words you want
to put in front of it but hidden is a
word that gives an association that I
don't like at all about it there was
nothing special about Otto Frank in his
dealings with the Wehrmacht by the way
you mentioned in your book only one
example of a delivery to the Wehrmacht
on June 5 1940 which is four weeks after
Holland was occupied so you would think
that it was a little more flesh on that
on that heavy sounding accusation of
collaboration which is not something and
for me therefore I am terribly
disappointed by the whole book in spite
of the fact that there are so many
moving stories about Otto Frank
you mentioned the example he went back
to the war to a man he met in Auschwitz
and where he had an argument with in
Auschwitz for me this was very much Otto
Frank he wanted to put things straight
it was a very straightforward
old-fashioned man morale as a sort of
19th century civilized man almost Bilger
to me I suddenly have this German word
that creeps into my mind and he would
certainly certainly in 1945 he did two
things he went looking for the man who
had denounced him in 41 he'll read in
the book if you don't know it is
incident I can't explain it but you'll
read it in the book somebody denounced
him to the Gestapo because of anti
German remarks he went looking for that
man and told the Dutch authorities that
this man should be put in jail and he
went looking for the man who thought
had helped him out and that was the man
who mrs. Lee said betrayed him I don't
know who betrayed and Frank the betrayal
is a whole different story than the
collaboration but the thing is without
collaboration that wasn't there wouldn't
have been any blackmail and the
blackmail is the point of the hidden
life of otto Frank I think this is all
air and I'm from that point of view very
disappointed in the book this is what I
wanted to say the hidden life of Otto
Frank I'm sorry that you see it like
that
I wrote it the hidden life of Otto Frank
because nobody knew about his life
everybody knew him as this father figure
his whole life was a mystery to people
so that's what I meant by the hidden
life of Otto Frank as far as the
collaboration that you're talking about
I do not call him a collaborator as far
as I'm concerned it's not could I speak
now because you've talked for quite a
long time and I think it's time I
answered your accusation yet I don't
consider him a collaborator but I do
think in 1945 what happened during the
war
could have made things very
uncomfortable for him and afterwards
I've been in touch with mitrice's family
and they told me that MEAP had said he
was very worried about those deliveries
to the vm Act and he was frightened they
would be discovered therefore that does
make him in a very vulnerable position
and unfortunately he'd met Tony Alice
who knew how to exploit people's
vulnerability and I think he was in that
position and clearly the Dutch
government has taken this book and the
whole issue of Tony allas seriously
enough to fund an investigation into the
betrayal so if it's a load of rubbish
which is what you want people to think
they wouldn't have done that they
wouldn't have taken it that seriously
because I don't have been ours or anyone
else betrayed and there are many
theories over the years there have been
many people who might have you know
thought of that eventually they would
have betrayed the Frank family and I
described him and what people knew that
they were there then you would sink this
through I don't know if ours betrayed if
it's possible it's not possible I don't
know but my objection is against the
fact that you call otto Frank a business
associate of now I don't yes I say you
made deliveries to the vehement know
your Bible says no but he was not in a
position to refuse those deliveries I
make that very very clear in the book
and you obviously haven't read it
correct I heard I have read so I did
contact you while I was writing this
book and I asked if maybe we could meet
and you've sent me an email back saying
I've closed the door and Anne Frank no
no no no no no no I've met her so Frank
a couple of times and I said I cannot
tell you anything specifically because I
didn't know him as a person just meeting
a person a couple of times doesn't give
enough information of knowing him and I
thought it was wonderful to write a book
about Otto Frank because I think he's
really worth of biography definitely and
if he you know did things in his life
that are bad why shouldn't we publish
about it it gives more insight into the
problems that people had in those days
man I wouldn't I wouldn't we know all
that you know the charade Ian made to
meet heroes out of villains and Germans
out of Heroes hey Otto was blackmailed
until the end of his life the arles
family who came forward after the book
was published said that I did have Dave
his brain inside I have it here
literally a complicated relationship
that continued until the day Frank died
this is a very good team Club yes but
that's from his family he know this from
a reg side of the publisher unlike I
said you know I mean it's just one
element of the book uh-huh it is a
biography of Otto
and there are some tremendously moving
stories in there and not only that my
whole when I was writing this book I
worked very closely with Biddy Elias
who's Otto's nephew and who loved Otto
dearly and he his 100% behind the book
as you well know because you've called
him to complain about me and his wife
sent you off with a flea in your ear yes
you did and they were very angry with
you why did you leave me I'm prankster
thing sorry why did you leave the Anne
Frank stick thing I didn't leave the N
Frank stating I'm an independent
historian at the moment but I don't see
what that's I'm Carolee Zed etre so I'd
like to address what you said because I
find it amazing that you can pick one
part of the story out and not the second
part why would I know Frank have written
that letter
clearing somebody knowing that this
person was a Dutch Nazi why would he
write that letter Otto Frank was as I
said I think a very straightforward
person and there is a very moving story
in the book about what happened what
Otto Frank did in the first world war he
was a soldier in the First World War and
ending an officer no no I want to give
an example of his behavior at the end of
the First World War when everybody went
home otto frank was stuck in france with
a couple of horses that he had his unit
has confiscated from a belgium farmer
and he had promised through that belgium
farmer when the war is over
you'll get these horses back so all the
soldiers were running home as quickly as
possible that otto frank works with
these two horses back to that belgium
farmer because he had given his word as
a person that when the war was over he
would give these horses back he walked
to belgium then walked all the way back
to Frankfurt where his family thought
you know here
probably died at the end of the at the
end of the war this is a wonderful story
and there's another wonderful story that
kids Annette it's gonna book precisely
but returning forces is a little bit
different ya know Knox was under the
impression that there's no Nazi had
saved his life by intercepting a letter
that denounced otto Frank to the German
authorities what he wrote in that letter
was this is a man who had nothing to do
with the Nazis that's very different
than saying this man saved my life
he exonerated the man from everything he
had done all the other Jews that he had
exposed to Nazis brothers man you said
he may have saved my life but he
betrayed many others and when I heard
that I will have nothing much he didn't
say that in 1945 he said that 1945 I
said that because he was scared he was
frightened that he himself would be
implicated in something and that's why
he wrote that letter tonight's lecture
is about this book there are many of us
who have questions to ask and so let's
move on we have a moderator up front we
have an author I'll start with a
different question there were some pages
to the original diary that were found
did otto or any of his friends talk
about why these missing pages were
originally left out of the original
publication well um all we know about
why it's from the man who received the
missing pages who had the missing pages
and he says he believes that the pages
were left out because they showed an
unflattering portrait of the marriage of
Anne's parents which is very possible I
think that is probably the explanation
for it but I don't think that Otto would
mind those pages being published today
because of course and complete Diaries
or as complete as we thought they were
in 1986 we published a while ago and I
think I think they actually add more to
our knowledge of Anne Frank and they're
very beautifully written
a question about the sources that you
refer to during the course of your
research would you mind telling us a
little bit about your sources and yes I
mean I started really with them vide
Ellis and his wife they have a lot of
original documents a lot of Otto's
letters a lot of family the whole Frank
family's letters they have those at home
so I was able to use those I also worked
at the Anne Frank archives Yan Frank's
ticketing archives in Amsterdam
I worked there every week for about a
year researching the book and received a
lot of help from the foundation they
were fantastic as far as giving me
access to all the material was concerned
and they also put me in touch with them
a lot of people who knew Otto Frank I
was able to go and talk to many people
who'd met him and also do telephone
interviews which for me was tremendous
to meet these people who I knew played
important roles in the lives of the
Frank family that was very wonderful for
me
I don't need a mic I had a very small
part in the work can you hear me back
there
the reflections of the diary and her
legacy something that my wife and I'd
collaborated on we put together a little
book in which she tried to find as much
as possible that I've written about Anne
Frank from the time that she had written
the book until the moment that we are
here today I think it's just incredible
that we at this point in time are trying
to restore everything that happened at
that time it's almost impossible to do
to reconstruct history what I think that
Carol Anne Lee has done in her biography
click roses and in this biography of the
hidden life of Otto Frank is to add
another piece of the mosaic so that we
have something that enables us to
understand something about the whole
history of that period Anne Anne Frank
of course is a very crucial part of that
history and I think we're very grateful
to Carol Anne Lee and to Buddha liason
to Jack Pollock and the whole host of
people who have been working assiduously
to reconstruct what happened in a
fashion that now enables us while we're
still alive and still remembering what
happened so that our children who will
be here after us when we are no longer
able to remember will have something to
hold on to but we cannot do what this
questioner has been asking us to do to
put together what was it specifically
that I don't write did that was wrong he
didn't do wrong any more than any one of
us did he was a hero in many ways
and we are able to do so much and that's
how I feel too I mean I'm sorry that
this lady feels so upset with the
portrayal of Otto from the book but the
fact is that I wrote the book because I
liked Otto Frank and I think he's a
remarkable he was a very remarkable man
and I mean he set up the Anne Frank
foundation in Amsterdam of course and
this wonderful organization here too
came out all that he did and so much
good is done not only because of Anne's
diary of course that was the springboard
for it all but if it wasn't for Otto we
would not admit police who save the
diary of course we would never we
wouldn't have half of the people that we
have now working against discrimination
in the world today and he deserves great
recognition for that I think and I did
you know that's one of the things that I
start say at the beginning of the
beginning of the book that he was a
remarkable man there's no doubt about it
and you know I really don't have very
much to criticize him for at all Jack
Paula kerger chairman emeritus up to
Anne Frank Center I think most of you
know me and I hope not going into all
the problems which have been discussed
here tonight
I want to make certain statements it is
almost impossible for anybody in today's
world to understand the pressures we
went through during the war and what
people do in the war
I can't question that I think it's
almost input I think I have I I feel we
should not even question what theory has
been happened that's a sad thing I'm
very very fortunate that before for what
documentation in Holland is going to
find out what's going to happen and I
would like to leave it as that
to write the book and let me see I think
was September 1999 but I mean I had
still had so much material from writing
the Anne Frank book so I really had a
bit of a head start with this one and
really it took two two and a half years
to write it in total but I mean I I'm
filled with gratitude for everybody who
I came into contact with during the
writing of this book because I you know
I was just so fortunate so many people
opened their memories to me and let
their own personal archives of
documentation and letters and so on so
you know I was very lucky I just want to
say two things one I think perhaps what
yogi means about the title is that the
use of the word hidden suggests that his
whole life was was in some way some way
needed to be hidden and in fact it's
just unknown it's not hidden but
secondly I wanted to say that one of the
in as far as I could tell the book is
rather well researched and and very
interesting and has a lot in it but
there was one aspect of it that
concerned me and therefore I happen to
know wasn't as well research as it might
have been it has to do with what you
refer to as the cantata and it was just
a very very incomplete
examination I couldn't catch that sorry
I didn't catch him it's what you refer
to as the cantata that was written my
name is Enid Federman and you spoke of
it in a very very very fragmented
partial way and it's a very very long
story night well um well you know I'm
sure
but other than that I wasn't interested
I mean um I'm sure another writer would
have written this book a completely
different way there's no doubt about it
no two writers write the same new trick
no two writers research the same way I
mean of course and I think if I had to
rewrite it now it would possibly be
different again but the book was very
well received when it came out in
Britain especially in Holland they were
very much divided there was some
extremely misleading articles in the
press and but at the same time you know
the critics were really divided in
Holland they either loved it or hated it
but well I hope people who read it here
mostly will find it enjoyable or
interesting at least enjoyable is not
the right word but I mean interesting
you know that you will that they will
take away something from reading the
book the gauze holes into ovens book so
I know the whole thing that the campus
being eliminated so when you are reading
that it's all coming back and I see it
but we went through Alan's blook and
Lunenburg and and even an open cattle
cars from goes holes into happens brick
that was generally 18 when the temples
eliminated really and only the sick once
stayed behind and some of the men's
barracks but many of the women we all
went by 8 the 18th and it was snowy and
it was horrible and it was unbelievable
ok thank you very much for coming you
said you are going to talk about the
trail major purpose of your being here
but would you put just one peanut on it
if not final brick in that structure can
you say if we do have a definitive
answer to the betrayal what I will
is that I think Tony Alice was behind
their betrayal I think that that's just
my personal opinion but at the same time
you know like I said the Dutch
government took this book so seriously
that they reopened the investigation
there have been other theories put
forward the FIR modern theory the theory
that the warehouseman betrayed them of
course he was investigated twice nothing
could be proved and then a book was
published a few years ago about Anne
Frank where the theory there was that it
was the cleaning woman who betrayed them
but it wasn't until this book was
published that the Dutch government
decided to reopen the investigation so I
think that says something but at the
same time you know it is a biography of
Otto Frank that's one element of it one
element only my name is Jack Wolfe and I
came in late so he so you might already
have covered this ok I want to ask you
what motivated you to deputy to take
this particular subject and you know I
you know and research it the number one
the number two what other research have
you done and what other books ever
have you written well I wrote a
biography of Anne Frank few years ago
and that was adapted into a children's
biography um this book I really wrote
because I found Otto Frank's character
so interesting and I found him such an
extraordinary character the period that
he lived through I mean he lived until
he was into his 90s and he had to deal
with the fame of Anne's diary and the
way he coped with what happened to him
in the camps and what happened to his
family in the camps I really wanted to
explore that because obviously you know
I'm not Jewish I haven't got any kind of
background as far as that is concerned
but the one you know I think you know it
the way he dealt with it was amazing I
think he was such a strong character and
I wanted to explore that in the book and
I think for any parent to have survived
without their children without their
spouse and then to have come back and to
have found that diary
and then to have had the courage and it
really did take courage to publish that
book and he had to have courage
throughout the rest of his life because
not everybody agreed with him publishing
the book in the first place I mean even
members of his own family where you know
they weren't totally happy with it at
first so he's a very remarkable
courageous man and I think you have to
like somebody a great deal to write a
book about them or you have to find them
a very intriguing character and I
certainly found him that so that's why I
wrote it I had Barbara Wyn director of
the Holocaust canceled Metro West
thank you for your for your presentation
but I'm wondering if you could clarify
something from from the reading that is
when you talk about otto Frank hoping to
to help the hitter mature to to kind of
be a guide for him a mentor for him and
do you do have indications of that from
the diary or it is just the relationship
that that they established through in
the attic and in the in the hiding place
and then afterwards in in Auschwitz
relationship between otto and pizza yes
I think from what I could gather from
the material that I found they really
drew closer together I think well you
know I mean he did what I didn't have a
son and Peter in a way did become like a
son to him when they were in hiding
because he didn't get along particularly
well with his own parents and Otto of
course became the teacher of the three
young people while they were in hiding
and I think we can see from Anne's diary
that Peter did turn to him a lot and he
admired otto frank greatly and then you
know when when they were in the camps it
was Peter who managed to get food for
Otto who came to see him because Peter
got a job in the postal department of
the camp and so he was slightly better
fed than some of the other prisoners and
so you know I mean it
he they were very close friends I think
towards the end and I think Otto saw a
lot in Peter that could be developed I
mean who talks of wanting to help you to
develop his potential but cause he
couldn't because of what happened what
was the source of that dialogue uh there
were some letters that I found some
documents or letters the author Frank
had written he wrote a lot of letters to
schoolchildren because of course many
many school children read the diary and
he personally answered every letter that
was sent to him fortunately he kept
carbon copies of all those letters and
there are many thousands of those
letters and somewhat nearly all of them
are kept in the archives of the Anne
Frank foundation in Amsterdam but there
were also some in life I keep mentioning
birdy because he has a large archive
because it's his family and I found some
material there and where Otto talked
about Peter it wasn't as much as I would
have liked I would have liked a clearer
picture myself but what I could find I
found I tried to put into the book just
want to make a general comment on about
the title um you know James Glick wrote
a great book about Richard Fineman and
it was called genius and whether or not
you agreed he was a genius it didn't
negate the merits of the book you know
he made a damn good case whether you
believed him or not it really doesn't
matter because he was a fascinating man
and second I think great works of art or
just works of art in general should be
judged on what's included and not what
you think might be missing because that
I think is irrelevant
well I agree thank you
I just want to know how you would react
to someone that would tell you that Tony
Euler's was not the betrayer about it
Frank well first of all I would say if
you read the book there are so many
elements that do add up I mean the
people who'd been put put forward before
as possible candidates for the betrayal
I mean they were not known Nazis they
were not known to have betrayed other
people they didn't move in those circles
they had no grudge against Otto Frank as
far as we know they didn't know him
personally and they as far as we know
they didn't hate Otto Frank but Tony
allas was a known anti-semite he was a
Nazi he moved in those circles he did
receive money for betraying people his
wife worked as a betrayer she worked for
the Gestapo doing that job and it just
seems to me I mean those are just some
very basic things that I pulled out but
it just seems to me that all the roads
lead back to him and the fact is you
know so many members of the Alice family
have come forward to say it was him his
brother his stepsister his son his
daughter his other son his granddaughter
his there are so many many of them and
they're not all in touch with each other
and I can't believe that they all sat
down together and said one day hey I
know let's go forward now this book is
out and say it was him I know some
people say well maybe they're motivated
by feelings of revenge but having met
them I don't think they are and in any
case it's not a very good form of
revenge because he's dead you know
nothing can happen to him now anyway but
again I would just say that the Dutch
government did see fit to reopen the
investigation